let's first get to the news of the week
recently we saw the comments from
president trump regarding the uh
the primary and the mail-in ballot
process that's been
created because of the coronavirus do
you share
the president's concerns about
how this process is going to go forward
i do i do uh you know obviously we have
an all mail in ballot right now for the
primary
for the general you know people want to
go
and they want to cast their vote they
should be able to go out there and do it
uh i'm not uh i'm not excited about it
i know there's a group that just filed a
federal lawsuit up in
carson city i know that's over in the
ninth circuit court of appeals right now
and uh you know this is something that
republicans and democrats both want
so you know i saw all those ballots
sitting in the garbage and that's scary
that's scary the uh general
feeling is that by having this mail-in
bout it will at least
allow more people to take part um
because of the any concerns about the
pandemic and concerns about
social distancing etc wouldn't that
actually
help your case for example your campaign
to have
the opportunity for more people to take
to take part
i i think it's great that you know uh we
have a lot of people voting
you know but the problem is is you know
there's also issues with that
ballot harvesting you know people
picking these uh
ballots up off the ground or i saw the
pictures
at the condominium complexes with just
you know tons and tons and tons of just
balance
you know laying in there uh you know i'm
not a fan of it
you know i've always been a fan of uh
you know a federal voter id card you
know
they have it in other countries i think
we should have it here
let's talk about the the race itself
this is a primary before we even talk
about
congresswoman lee what do you believe
helps you stand out from the other
republicans uh that are running right
now
well i'm the only true conservative john
in this race
i came into this race obviously
frustrated about
susie lee i'm running i have won
you know one one opponent uh who has
uh that we're running against and he's
not conservative
he was a one-time treasurer he tried to
raise
more taxes as a one-time republican
treasurer than
any others in in history tried to raise
an airport tax a meal tax
and a corporate tax which john obviously
after this pandemic if if he was able to
implement them
it would have been very very difficult
for for many people out there many small
businesses
across the board and tourism too imagine
we had an airport tax it would have
crushed us
so you know i'm running against a
somebody who's complete opposite of me
you know i'm a second amendment guy
john i i was the only person who got the
uh nra endorsement and they don't take
that lightly
you know dan schwartz he wanted to ban
certain types of rifles um obviously
you know there's other things too i mean
he's for amnesty i'm for border security
uh you know he was a never trumper
and i've always been you know supportive
of our president and i am still through
this day and
uh you know this is a seat that we know
we can take back
um president trump won it by a point and
a half and 16.
and um you know it's a 50 50 split
you know this is republican democrat
district pretty much 50 50.
and um you know not going to susie lee
just yet but
you know obviously you know she's not
working for the people
and and that's why i got on board i
think one of your ads you
i think you refer to mr schwartz as a as
a
liberal something along those lines uh
i i don't have it off the top of my head
you might be the first person i can
remember that's referring
with that name with that kind of uh he
called me big dan so on the ballot just
so you know john i'm big dan rhodeimer
it might be because i'm
six foot seven 300 pounds uh and i don't
like to call him little dan i think you
know
but i will call him liberal damn but you
know the fact is
you know he's he's he is aoc
on amnesty he's bloomberg on guns and
he's pelosi on taxes
uh that's not what congressional
district 3 wants
what does congressional district 3 won
why don't you think they want susie lee
again
well susie lee came in and i was hoping
she was going to do a good job i really
was
she came on as a moderate or claimed
that she was a moderate
and then she voted with the president i
think it was the same amount
about 1.5 percent of the time that's on
a fun fact
that's less than the squad right that's
not what
cd3 wants she came in she um
uh right away she started with the whole
impeachment thing the russian collusion
thing
you know instead of getting things done
you know i talk to republicans and
democrats
you know democrats like me republicans
like me um
you know we have the same issues you
know i go to these churches
you know every weekend before covet
started and i talk to the people
and you know the three major issues you
know that i hear
you know from majority of democrats are
they want
good health care they want a good paying
job and they want good schools for their
kids
that doesn't sound much different than
us republican you know and it's just
getting the word
out there you know they even told me
they said you know when i came on like
damn we want to we want you on fox news
all the time
you know the fact is i want to be on fox
i want to be i mean i would
i have no problem being on products but
the fact this is i want to be on cnn i
want to be on msnbc
so that we can convey the message to you
know to the other side
because we have the same issues do you
have the same solutions
well right now we don't have any right
right now the president came in
okay we have uh the strongest economy
we've ever had in u.s history before
copenhagen it was incredible
okay and then we have you know susie lee
coming in
who's you know trying to raise taxes
okay that's not good for small
businesses you know i'm a small business
owner
you know i understand how how hard it is
to make payroll sometimes
you know uh you know you know the fact
is
is you know i look at it like when i go
to dc
you know i'm going to bring my business
experience there and right now
you know susie lee you know she tried to
revoke
trump's tax cuts she's doing everything
opposite she's
you know unfortunately and i hate to say
and i don't want to be
you know derogatory towards it but you
know at the end of the day she's become
pelosi's puppet
and that's not what nevada wants okay
that's not what congressional district 3
wants that's not what the united states
of america wants
you know we need jobs and and we need to
boost our economy after this covenant
situation
um what would you say to those who
suggest that
experience political specifically
experience is important
in uh and someone who is
uh serving on behalf of their district
on behalf of the country
mr schwartz has as you mentioned uh done
work up in carson city
uh susie lee has now been almost two
years or so in
washington talk about your political
experience and how you think that would
be useful
uh if you win well
i look at like this president trump did
he have any political experience coming
in
he was a business owner and he ran the
country like business
he's done a great job and uh yes
i went to law school okay i went to ave
maria law school
i you know i helped write a school
safety bill
i have been involved with the republican
party
and you know the issues that people are
coming to me
with they're not getting rectified
they're not getting fixed
and dan schwartz he's not
what he's not what the republican party
wants but
at the same point he's not what cd3
wants
uh you know he has like i said earlier i
mean he tried to raise so many different
taxes he's a one-time treasurer
his political experience uh hurt him and
he's not even running on it you know
he's running on
he won't discuss his past he claims that
you know he's uh he's a trumper but
you know he's never endorsed trump he's
never
went out there on the on the floor uh
when when we had the republican nominee
of president trump he was bashing the
president then and then he went out
i don't know if you heard about this but
he went on the kevin wall show a week
and a half ago and
bashed the president for how he's
handling coven
and then he doubled up and said i don't
even know what
the president's thinking putting uh
jared kushner
on the uh the covet task force i mean
that's crazy
you know i think the president's doing a
good job
i think he's doing a great job and um
you know after this coveted situation uh
is over
and we need to rebuild our economy you
know i want to hold china responsible
for this i want those manufacturing jobs
to come back here
okay the united states of america to
nevada i welcome them
is it more you just just follow up on
that real quick is it more important to
support the president with regards to uh
the coronavirus response
or is it more important to i guess for
lack of a better phrase be true to
yourself
what if those things are different
people are allowed to be you know have
people learn to have a disagreement with
the other side or your own side
absolutely and you can and it's about
getting along and that's the thing
even you know when i come and i and i go
to dc
you know it's about working across the
aisle it's about working with other
people
and right now susie lee's not doing it
you know she's not working with the
other side
she's just listening to pelosi over and
over and over again
and that's not helping nevada it's not
i mean right now uh with this pandemic
in place you know you know we need to
open
a safe responsible way you know people
are hurting right now john
uh you know people are losing their jobs
people can't put food on the table
people can't pay
pay their rent they can't pay their
mortgages uh casinos are
are closing left and right
down in launchland you know they just
lost 400 jobs
the oldest casinos i mean this is a
scary time but
we you know these are they're simple
solutions to major issues okay
and you know
give me a simple solution to uh
getting yeah we're talking about
obviously cd3 we
let's talk about las vegas what's a
simple solution to
getting through the coronavirus and and
getting businesses back open again
okay so 11 of our 24 counties okay have
less than 24 000 people
all right sisalak is going off of
california he's riding their coattails
they have 40 million people john we have
three million people
all right we need the leaders in these
counties to open
in a way in which you know is safe and
responsible
you know we've been at we were at phase
zero for for how long
you know governor susana would go on
there and talk for hours but he wouldn't
give us
oh it's the data he would tell us what
it is right
um you know thank goodness we had a
drive-through
at our restaurant because otherwise we
would have been in serious trouble
and but i talk to people every day
you know and i say what are the issues
and before
when i was talking to republicans and
democrats you know it was healthcare
you know and uh and schooling but now
it's we need to reopen
we need to reopen and we need to reopen
soon okay because
you know we're going to go bankrupt
um any other uh things you'd like to
address i'm out of questions
you're out of questions come on we could
go for another 10 minutes
no this is a seat we have to win uh you
know we have to take back
um you know i believe we will
take this seat back um you know we've
been running a great campaign
and um we're going to continue to win
and
we'll take back nevada and we'll will
help nevada
uh after this coronavirus uh
pandemic is over um we'll bring jobs
back
and um uh i'm confident
that uh we're we're gonna we we were the
we were the hardest hit during the
recession
the last recession john and it took
nevada the longest to come back
i don't want that to happen i want jobs
now i want jobs coming back now
i want i want people to be able to get
back to work
and that's what i'm going to fight for
so john thank you god bless nevada
and god bless america thank you for the
time then it's good to meet you and uh
good luck to you sir
thanks pal have a great day take care